our OB leads a human hormone a
prescription medicine or a deadly
narcotic actually it can be all three in
fact
opioids are not so foreign they're found
in our bodies secreted by the pituitary
and adrenal glands endogenous opioids
are neurotransmitters that our body
synthesizes to regulate our response to
stimuli things like emotions motivation
and pain are all regulated by endogenous
opioids exogenous opioids as a prefix
EXO suggests or opioids not made or
found in our body it can be natural like
morphine semi synthetic like heroin or
entirely synthetic like naloxone both
types of opiates bind to G
protein-coupled receptors the activation
of g proteins is what causes the effect
of opioids here is an example of a mu
receptor with an agonist bound to the
active site broadly speaking when
opioids bind and activate GPCRs the
activated GPCRs inhibit the transmission
of a neuronal signal from one neuron to
another one way in which opioids
modulate neuronal signaling is through
postsynaptic inhibition as the opioids
bind to GPCRs colored in red potassium
channels are opened and the positive
potassium ions leave the neuron thus
leaving no signal to be relayed to the
next neuron zoomed in we see the
activated g-protein release it's G beta
gamma complex which activates the
potassium channel and causes
hyper-polarization naloxone is a
synthetic derivative of oxymorphone
intended to reverse the antagonizing
effects of opioids in action while on
the locks on replaces the opioids bound
to gpcrs due to its higher affinity it
doesn't activate the g-protein every day
130 plus people die from an opioid
overdose ten point three million people
misused prescriptions just in 2018 if
there's one thing you can do to address
the epidemic avoid opioid derived
prescriptions and recognize that
treatment not punishment is the answer
you